tout ça sera carré de l'intérieur s'est
démené comme ça remplacer une charpente
en bois cacher des visiteurs par un
espace touristique panoramique ce projet
dans quelques heures seulement vise à
mettre en valeur le travail des artisans
avec des moyens modernes on entendait
beaucoup à gauche à droite qu'il était
nécessaire rapidement donc situer la
charpente à l'identique et c'est vrai
que ça nous a interrogé en tant qu
architecte parce que vous vivez ou
l'intérim siècle et l'on se dit
finalement le patrimoine a été détruit
c'est dramatique mais pour quelle raison
devrait absolument le reconstituer à
l'identique sa chance ça ne correspond
plus à des techniques contemporaines du
verre du métal des tuiles de cuivre sur
les réseaux sociaux les réactions sont
bien sûr tout en nuances certains
évoquent un génie architectural quand
d'autres dénoncent une insulte faite à
nos ancêtres
le concours international annoncé doit
permettre de laisser place à
l'imagination pour la profession c'est
un vrai faire valoir c'est à dire de
montrer que les architectes sont des
gens créatifs et qu'ils ont la
possibilité de répondre un concours
international
donc on souhaite avant tout que ce
concours sera ouvert à tous dont nous
toute petite agence pour pouvoir
participer et montrer des idées vu les
sommes collectées le budget ne sera pas
un problème reste donc le débat culturel
contrairement à paris la charpente de la
cathédrale de dijon a été entièrement
refaite au 19e siècle comme viollet le
duc à notre dame
l'architecte charles suisse s'est permis
des fantaisies alors l'idée d'une
toiture vitré peut faire son chemin
ça va complètement bouleverser ce qu'on
a comme image des cathédrales avec la
possibilité d'avoir une vue panoramique
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant
on fait une véritable transition
historique entre cet aspect rustique
brut du bois des charpentes avec quelque
chose de totalement moderne épuré
différents réaliser un toit de verre à
paris dans un délai évoqué de cinq ans
serait possible le plus long à surmonter
certainement les contraintes
administratives